Okay. Welcome everybody. This is a session on KRAS inhibitors from discovery to
patient outcomes.
Thanks to all of you for coming.
So I'm Frank McCormick. I'm the chair of the session today, and I'm going to give a
bit of background on RAS biology, so we're all on the same page in understanding
the challenges of targeting RAS and what RAS proteins do in normal cells
and in cancer cells.
I will very briefly summarize attempts to target downstream effectors, particularly
RAF and PI3 kinase alpha, and then summarize again very
briefly some of our efforts to develop KRAS inhibitors at
the Frederick National Lab in collaboration with BridgeBio Oncology
Therapeutics.
And then I will hand over the podium to my friend and colleague, Cameron Pitt, and
then on to Mallika Singh, the finale. Is that good?
Good. Okay, let's go.
So
let's skip through my disclosures so you don't have time to read them.
Okay. So first of all, some background on the RAS pathway
and also a way of introducing people in my lab who are actually working on this
pathway.
So, I think you're all well aware that RTKs activate RAS
through activation of SOS, which puts RAS proteins from the inactive
state into the active state, and then in normal cells,
RAS's only function that we know of in normal cells is to activate the MAP
kinase pathway.
RAS proteins are turned off by GAPs, of which neurofibromin and
RASA2 and A3 seem to be the major GAPs that work on canonical RAS
proteins. So these proteins kick RAS back into the inactive state, and we go back
to where we were.
So,
you may think that this is like textbook stuff and all, everything is known about
the RAS pathway that needs to be known, but you'd be wrong because some of what is
in the textbooks is actually not correct or requires revision.
For example, we think the mechanism by which RAS proteins get activated
by SOS needs revision, and Matt Sale in my lab, a
very brilliant postdoctoral fellow, has been working on a new
mechanism for activation of SOS.
Part of the activation of RAS is thought to involve the
SHP2 protein tyrosine phosphatase.
And Matt has shown that in fact, in contrast to what's been in the literature,
the phosphatase activity of SHP2 is irrelevant to its role in
activating RAS. And we won't have time to talk about this today, but it's part of a
story that's kind of late breaking.
I have to say that our analysis of the phosphatase activity of SHP2 and
its role in signaling has been done in kind of parallel with Ben Neal, who's made
similar observations. And Ben will be presenting his data at the major
symposium on Monday at 12:30. So again, we coordinated our results even though
we've found the same thing independently.
It's a paradigm shift in how SHP2 works in activating
RAS proteins.
We still don't really understand exactly the role of the SHOC2 PP1C complex that we
discovered back in 2006, and which RAS proteins are involved in this, whether
it's mRAS
or other canonical RAS proteins. And there's a role for
RIT1 in activating RAF indirectly,
and this protein is regulated by LZTR1 by degradation, and
LZTR1 may have a role in degrading other proteins as
well. So still lots of things to work on in this pathway, some of which are
relevant to normal cell signaling and some more in the context of cancer.
And a plug for Miranda, who's in the audience, I think somewhere here. Is she?
Right there. She has a poster on Monday.
And I urge you all to go and look at her poster.
She's been interested in how RRAS2 and other RAS proteins
are involved in activating PI3 kinase, particularly in the context of helico
mutations of PI3 kinase in human cancer.
And then Rony Francois, who may be in the audience somewhere, also has a
poster, which I would urge you to look at. Hi, Rony.
Should have guessed he'd be in the front row.
Rony has been looking at various aspects of SHOC2 and including trying to find out
what the phosphatase is that
actually phosphorylates RAF1 on the negative phosphorylation site.
So that's how things work in normal cells.
And again, in normal cells, there's no evidence that I know of that RAS proteins do
anything except MAP kinase in normal cells.
And if anyone has any evidence, please let me know because we've been trying hard
to find any. However, things are very different in cancer
cells. So they're different in several different ways.
So in cancer cells with mutations in RAS, such as codon 12 and
13 and 61, as you all know, these mutations essentially make RAS
proteins resistant to all forms of GAP.
So RAS proteins accumulate to varying degrees in their
GDP-bound state, and therefore signal downstream more
independently of growth factors in a different way.
So in normal cells, signaling is very controlled and pulsatile, as shown here
by a standard sort of analysis of signaling.
After adding EGF to cells, you get a blip in RAS GTP.
It goes away again. A blip in phospho-ERK goes away again.
And you can measure this
by biochemical means like this or by measuring phospho-ERK in a
single-cell readout, as done by John Auluck here.
And you can see a pulsatile signaling of spikes of MAP kinase
signaling in response to growth factors.
And the key thing here is the more growth factor you add, the more spikes you get.
But every spike is very tightly controlled in terms of its size and its
duration.
And in normal cells, normal cells can interpret different growth factors
differently. So
NGF, EGF, FGF probably create different series of spikes, and
this kind of Morse code is interpreted differently in different contexts and in
different cell types. The outcome of this pathway activation is very
different. It could be proliferation, it could be differentiation, it can be
involved in cognition and many other aspects of cell biology.
But in cancer cells where we have mutant RAS, things are very different.
Now, RAS GTP just stays on the whole time, doesn't really care very much
about adding growth factors. So we go from a very controlled
pulsatile sort of code to signaling into this sort of tonic
noise of phospho-ERK activation.And this conversion from
control to persistent activation of phosphoerk is sufficient to
transform cells. That alone is probably the first step in
transformation driven by MAP kinase.
So
an obvious experiment would be to find drugs that block RAF kinase
activity.
And so we tried this many, many years ago.
Before most of you were born, we developed a RAF inhibitor called sorafenib,
and it worked in many cancer types, pretty much everywhere except in cancers
with mutant RAS.
It's not what we expected. And later on, several
investigators, including one of my heroes, Neil Rosen, who's in the audience right
here,
who I'm quoting here without his permission,
showed that RAF inhibitors create a paradoxical
activation of RAF kinase. So here he's
measured levels of phospho-MEK, a substrate of RAF, and as you increase
doses of different RAF inhibitors, you see an increase in RAF
activity. This is not what we expected at all, just the opposite, in fact,
but it's true of all of these RAF inhibitors.
And we now know, as many of you will know who follow this field, this is because,
again, of paradoxical activation of RAF.
So RAF, we didn't know at the time, but RAF acts as a dimer coupled to RAS in the
plasma membrane, as I'll show you in the next slide.
But if one of these protomers is inhibited by particular drugs like these, the
inactive protomer hyperactivates the wild type or
the drug-free counterpart to give you an increased signal output.
So RAF essentially is booby-trapped so that RAF inhibitors don't work, and that
put a cold shower on the whole field of developing RAF
inhibitors. People have tried to develop paradox breakers, but
this has got even more complicated now because from the work of Mariano
Barbacid and,
more recently, Julian Downward,
it now seems that the RAF proteins, RAF1 particularly, has a scaffold
function. So inhibiting the kinase is not sufficient to turn off RAS
signaling. You actually have to get rid of the protein altogether or prevent the
RAS protein from binding to RAF1.
So there's some structural component of the RAF kinase which is important, at least
from mouse models, which is not addressed by kinase inhibitors.
So we're trying to address that in the lab.
A graduate student just passed her qualifying exams last week.
Maria is working on a project in collaboration with Keyvan Shokat to
find a new way of preventing RAS activating RAF that doesn't cause
paradoxical activation.
But this slide is meant to show you that we were sort of ahead of ourselves in
developing RAF inhibitors early on because the activation process is much more
complicated than we expected.
So we'll start here with the inactive RAF held in the cytoplasm
by a dimer of 14.3.3 proteins, each bound through specific
phosphosites on the RAF protein. So this is the inactive state.
The RAS binding domain, the RBD, is accessible, and when RAS is in the
GTP state, it can bind there and recruit this complex to the plasma
membrane. And in the process of recruiting it, the CRD, the
cysteine-rich domain, which is buried in the RAF protein here, comes
exposed and starts interacting with lipids in the plasma membrane.
So this is the first step towards dimerization and
activation.
Now, the phosphate that kept the 14.3.3 proteins in the inactive state, we
call the molecular handcuffs, that keep the RAF protein inactive.
This phosphorylation site, if it remains phosphorylated, could result
in the reaction going backwards and 14.3.3 binding again to going back to the
inactive state.
So under certain circumstances, a complex that, again, we discovered in
2006, a complex of MRAS, PP1C, and
SHOK2, is recruited to the plasma membrane and dephosphorylates
this phosphate specifically. And that prevents the reaction going backwards and
pushes the whole thing towards activation.
So cancer cells are particularly dependent on SHOK2 much more than normal
cells. Lucy Young in the lab has shown that you don't need to dephosphorylate
T259 to go through dimerization. But
if you do dephosphorylate, the reaction goes much more efficiently.
So cancer cells depend on this extra step, presumably because the flux through the
pathway is much faster and you can't afford to go backwards.
You just want to keep driving activation of the pathway.
And again, Roni is trying to figure out what the kinase is that puts this
phosphorylation on RAF in the first place.
So still a lot to learn about this activation process.
Debbie Morrison and Michael Eck and the group at Frederick have solved
various components of this pathway
by crystallography or by cryo-EM.
We haven't yet got a full idea of what the whole activation complex looks
like. And we're really keen to know this because we know that activation of RAF in
cancer cells is different to normal cells, because
RAS cancer cells depend on RAF1 exclusively to
activate the MAP kinase pathway in cancer, whereas normal cells don't care
about which isoform of RAF is engaged.
So there are real differences between the signaling in normal cells and
in cancer cells we might be able to exploit if we understood more about the
biochemistry. So that's what we're trying to do.
Now, you all know from textbooks, if you look up,
for example, on Google what the RAS proteins do, you get a number of figures like
this from different textbooks showing that RAS can activate a whole range of
different downstream effectors.
If you ask ChatGPT or Claude, as we now use,
you get the answer that the major effector is MAP kinase.
A secondary one, which is important in most cancers, is PI3 kinase.
And then occasionally, RalGDS is a real effector.
And we think the truth is much along these lines, that some of these engagements
are important in very specific cell types under certain circumstances,
but mostly MAP kinase is critical, and in some tumor cells,
some alleles of RAS activate PI3 kinase, and that helps
the transformed phenotype dramatically.
And other downstream effectors are most likely, again, important in certain
contexts.So,
how can this possibly be that a
protein like Ras can interact with so many different effectors, each of which has a
completely different structure?
So these aren't all conserved family members, they're all completely different
proteins.
And at least
one answer is this, that
Ras proteins, the canonical Ras proteins, are part of a super family of related
proteins, Ras, Ras2, Raf-1, M-Ras, and
others. Each of these is regulated by GAPs and GEFs, some of them shared,
some of them unique, and they activate their own private pathways.
And in normal cells, these swim lanes are kept separate because of the affinity
of Ras proteins for their effectors basically prevents them crossing over
into the other swim lanes.
So they are very well controlled, spatially and temporarily.
But if you mutate Ras and it starts to accumulate in the active state and
frequently in tumor cells, you overexpress Ras to higher levels,
then the mutant Ras protein can cross over into the other swim lanes
and now pick up effectors that are normally meant to be engaged by
these closely related family members.
And this kind of promiscuity that's a neo function of Ras in tumor cells
presents therapeutic opportunities, obviously, because these interactions we don't
think happen normally.
Somanchu, Frederick, and myself have just written a review on this topic
to explain from a structural level how these Ras family proteins can
actually cross over and interact with one another.
So these are structures of Ras proteins bound to either Raf or PI3 kinase and
RalGDS, and these are the points of contact.
And on these alignments here, you can see from these blocks where the things are
identical, most of the Ras proteins share a very similar identical core,
but as you can see from this red and
green here,
Ras subtypes differ in specific amino acids to give maybe 10 to
20-fold difference in binding between different effectors.
That seemed to be enough to keep them compartmentalized in normal cells, but again,
when you overexpress them, it's enough to allow them to cross over.
So this will be published soon and you can dig in deeper.
So we've taken advantage of one of these interactions, that is the interaction
between K-Ras and P110 alpha, to develop a drug we call the breaker,
which is now in clinical trials. This is a drug that binds to PI3
kinase alpha at the Ras binding domain, this is up here, and
prevents any Ras protein
binding at this site, with one or two exceptions.
So normally, K-Ras binds to PI3 kinase alpha at about 20 micromolar
KD, which is not enough to have any effect in cells.
In fact, this interaction is kind of hard to detect by standard pull down
methods, although it can be done.
But in the presence of a glue compound that we discovered in collaboration with
Daiichi Sankyo, we're able to stick K-Ras onto PI3 kinase
alpha, increase the affinity down to six nanomolar, and then solve
the structure. And based on this structure, we're able to find a drug
that actually prevents this interaction.
And this was a very nice collaboration, again, between the Frederick National Lab
and the medicinal chemists and biochemists at BridgeBio Oncology
Therapeutics.
This is one of Somanchu's papers also measuring the binding constant of various
K-Ras mutants with PI3 kinase alpha.
So wild type has a binding constant of about 20 micromolar, but the two most common
alleles of K-Ras, G12D and V, bind significantly more tightly
with single-digit micromolar binding constants.
So this suggests, but doesn't prove, that one of the reasons that these two are
very common in cancer is they actually gain the ability to activate PI3
kinase. And that confers other properties on cells which
presumably contribute to their
malignant phenotype. So this drug is in clinical trials right now, and
hopefully we'll present data on those clinical trials later in the year.
Here's another function of Ras, which probably no one in the audience is thinking
about
because no one really cares about it except me, apparently.
And that is
mutant Ras proteins, as well as activating effectors directly, are
involved in cell-cell contact.
Transformation was originally defined as a process in which transformed cells
overcome cell-cell contact inhibition. That's a hallmark of cancer.
So I'm just showing you this to remind you that Ras proteins have other biology
other than just activation of effector pathways.
So this little example here, this is the ephrin signaling family, which is the
most abundant form of tyrosine kinases in the genome.
It's 13 different members. And the cool thing about this is that in one
cell presents the ligand, ephrin ligand, and the other cell
is the recipient of this signal, presents the receptor.
And when the ligand binds to the receptor, it sends a signal to the receiving cell,
obviously. And this is often a negative signal, which stops cells from growing.
So this is how cells find their way around the body.
So such as, for example, during neurite outgrowth.
One cell comes to a point where there's ephrins, and the
receiving cell says, "Go away," and it goes somewhere else.
So this is how cells know where they're supposed to be and where they're not
supposed to be.
Now, ephrin B itself, the ephrin receptor, is a tumor suppressor, and it
allows malignant progression of colon cancer, shown from Hans Clevers.
And we now think this is because mutant Ras in colon cancer enables these cells to
escape from negative signals through this ephrin signaling system.
So this experiment was done by Antonio Navarro when he was a graduate student in
the lab in collaboration with our postdoc, Pao, at the time.
This shows you that if you add soluble ephrin ligand to cells, as shown
here, you actually inhibit the MAP kinase pathway.
So you see a dose-dependent inhibition of phospho work in response to the
ligand. So this is a receptor tyrosine kinase, but it's a negative one.
And it's negative because it recruits Ras A1 GAP to the
membrane, where it turns off Ras.
If you get rid of Ras A1 GAP by knocking it out, then ephrin signaling goes the
other way and is now a positive signal in the cell.
So mutant Ras, of course, is resistant to GAPs.
So mutant Ras proteins can't tell when they're being told to go away by
ephrins in the neighboring cells.So the presence of a mutant protein then makes the
cell able to travel around the body and migrate and metastasize,
and completely ignore negative signals from ephrins, would normally stop it from
proliferating.
I guess pretty cool, right? Thank you.
Okay,
enough Ras biology.
Now I want to switch to a very brief summary of our efforts to find drugs that bind
to KRas directly, that have come out of the Ras Initiative at Frederick,
Maryland, and again, all the drug discovery work recently has been done in
collaboration with BridgeBio Oncology Therapeutics.
So this is some of the leadership team that's helped get this thing started in the
first place. This is Harold Varmus's idea back in 2013.
He decided that the field hadn't made enough progress in targeting
pancreatic cancer, so let's start an initiative really focusing on KRas
in pancreatic cancer and other diseases, but that was the main
focus. Doug Lowy was the deputy and still is.
Ed Harlow, collaborator, and these are some of the key players some of you know
very well at the Ras National Initiative.
I'm sorry to say that none of these scientists here were able to come to the
meeting today because the HHS decided that
scientists working for the Ras Initiative should not be allowed to travel to
scientific meetings. So that's Kennedy at work.
So they are stuck back in Maryland, not allowed to come to the meeting.
I think this is a total tragedy because many of you know these people who interact
with all of you as part of the scientific community.
They're not allowed to come to the meeting.
Anyway, these are the advisors to the Frederick National Lab
Ras Initiative. And together we've
solved a lot of structures, done a lot of biochemistry, and understood a lot of Ras
biology. But I think our major contributions really have been
codevelopment of drugs that hit KRas directly and the PI3 kinase breaker
that I mentioned before. So we have three brand new
first-in-class compounds already in clinical trials.
And I'm not going to show clinical data today because they're all pursuing going up
through the clinical trial dose escalation and the BBOT team will
present clinical data hopefully later in the year.
So our drug discovery effort started way back
early on in the program when we decided that we had to hit Ras in the GTP-bound
state because we were going after T12D and V, which are the two most
prevalent mutants in pancreatic cancer.
And we're pretty sure that at least T12V will be mostly bound to the GTP-bound
state because it has very little intrinsic GTPase.
T12D is kind of intermediate between C and D, but it
still has a slower cycle time than
T12C.
So we assumed that we'd have to have a different strategy to hit
the KRas than the one that Kevan brilliantly described in 2013 at the same
time as the Ras Initiative started.
So we went after the same pocket actually, but we were targeting
histidine-95 because we wanted to pan a KRas drug
only. And that's the only amino acid which is different between KRas,
H and N Ras in that part of the protein.
So we found a compound that bound covalently to the histidine-95
and in the GTP-bound state. And it was active in cells.
This is the original structure that Ana Maciar worked on.
But we couldn't progress this compound because it was too reactive.
Reacting with histidine required too much of an electrophilic warhead, and we
weren't able to convert that into a proper drug.
But we learned a lot about how to get compounds into the
GTP-bound state of the Ras protein, which had been
virtually impossible previously with the T12C approach that you're all
familiar with. So we had expertise in that area, and then
we recruited Eli Wallace and Pedro and
Ben and Bin and Ray.
Sorry,
Eli first, and then Pedro, and then Bin, and then Ray and Kerson.
And Yue was then at Lawrence Livermore National Lab, so now he's now at BBOT.
So this group together
developed drugs that bind to the GTP-bound state of
T12C and pan KRas. So these are the two drugs which
are now proceeding through the clinic.
And a quick plug here for James from BBOT, who's giving a
poster later in the meeting. Or is it a talk? I forget.
So these are the two compounds, both published, so you can dig into the
details by all means. The real key thing here is they bind to the
GTP-bound state as well as the GDP-bound state.
So what's the advantage of that? Well, we don't know yet, obviously, because we
haven't got the clinical readouts.
But at least we can see in cell lines that
the on state compounds
engage Raf much more rapidly than, at that time, the two
approved off state compounds, because this compound doesn't
have to wait for Ras to cycle between the GTP and the GDP-bound state.
It just goes in there and reacts directly with the GTP-bound form of the
Ras protein. Whereas these two drugs have to wait until GTP is
hydrolyzed to GDP, and then they can hit the target.
And that's a very slow process, even for T12C.
So it should engage the target more quickly.
It could also make the tumor cells less likely to get
resistance by overexpression of KRas or by upstream signaling,
both methods of increasing the load of Ras GTP and
making off state drugs less able to find the target.
So these are potential benefits to be determined as the drugs
progress through the clinic.
So how do we get the compounds to bind into that pocket, which doesn't really exist
in the
classical GDP-bound form?
Well, the ability to do that is based on the fact that the switch one
region, which is where the effective binding region, where
Raf kinase is and other effectors bind.
Switch one can flop back and forth between an open state as
shown here or a closed state here when the switch one is now locked down
onto the nucleotide state.So this is called state one,
confusingly, and this is called state two.
This was first identified by Fred Whittinghoffer and Robert Kalbitzer
many years ago, but it's been sort of rediscovered here by Simanshu
using crystallography in which he's found different crystal forms of Ras
proteins can exist in the switch one,
or the state one or the state two state.
We know this is the productive state, the state two, because when you
co-crystallize the protein with a Raf RBD, it looks exactly like
the state two shown here.
Okay, so point here is that when
our drugs bind into the switch two pocket, they
displace the switch one region, so that it now
exists in state one. So this is a P31 analysis of the
gamma phosphates and the alpha and beta phosphates in Ras.
This is in state two, the productive state.
When we add drug, it moves to state one, which is the unproductive
state where the switch one region is swinging out and can't interact with the
effectors.
And we can see this also in crystal structures, which is published in this
paper as I described earlier on. So here we have the compound in the
switch two pocket. Its binding pose and interactions look virtually
identical between the GDP state and the GTP-bound state.
The difference though is that switch one is now pushed out into the
floppy state, into the outside, in the state
one configuration, which is not productive.
So this is how the compound's able to bind.
It sort of looks like it's binding to GDP, and it more or less binds in the same
way, except the switch one pocket is now in an
unproductive configuration, and you can read about that in this in more detail.
So that principle allows us to find compounds that basically hit the
GTP bound forms of mutant Ras. They still bind GTP, but now switch one is
pushed away so they can't engage effectors, and that enables us to turn
off any effector interaction.
So that's all I'm going to say. I'm now going to hand over the podium to my
ex-graduate student, Cameron Pitt.
Here he is seen receiving his graduate degree on the
campus at Mission Bay. So I'll maybe take a couple of questions before I hand
over to Cameron.
Any questions, please?
Neil Rosen has a question.
How does KRAS
migrate and
metastasize?
Yeah. Okay. The question is, how do KRAS proteins stimulate migration?
Well, it looks like it does it through the MAP kinase pathway,
and that's based on, at least in MEFs, based on the fact that
KRAS knockout MEFs stop migrating, but you can rescue
that with an activated allele of Raf, MEK, or Erk.
So that alone is enough to make MEFs
proliferate.
Okay. Yeah.
Neil is saying it's more complicated than that, which of course I totally agree
with. So MAP kinase can be responsible, or maybe it's necessary, but Neil
is reporting that inhibition of Raf results in
feedback activation of other RTKs, which can activate Rac, which has a
historical role in migration from back in the old Alan Ridley and
Alan Hall days. So definitely more than one mechanism, but Erk alone
can support it to some extent.
If Ben Neal were here, he'd be asking two questions.
I guess he's not. Okay.
He's here. He's back there.
Is he?
Any more questions?
If not, I'll hand over to Cameron. Thank you very much. Thank you.
All right. Thanks to the organizers for inviting me to participate in this
discussion, and thanks to Frank for that embarrassing photo of
how much older I am now.
These are my disclosures.
So despite the huge advance in this
field, when Kevan and his group discovered the allosteric switch two
pocket for targeting of G12C,
and
tremendous progress to date,
what we've seen is that
these three mutations, G12D, G12V, and G12C, remain
a huge issue, and it's really impossible to
overstate that this is a huge unmet need with over
150,000 US patients per year without any approved therapy.
And in addition, not just the prevalence, but also there's real
prognostic impact of that. We've seen that, at least in pancreatic
cancer, there's a worse prognosis conferred by these mutations.
And pancreatic cancer is truly a KRAS-dependent disease,
as we've seen.
And the recent advance of draxaparabve, incredible
data which has shown us that KRAS is
truly the only real important driver in that
indication.
This could really allow us to cover
the large majority of mutants in that indication.
But if you look at the abundance
of different mutants in different KRAS indications, what
we see is that the relative abundance differs pretty dramatically,
that each of these indications likely has a preference for
different mutants, and in different contexts, different mutants may function
differently.
And thus-Different mutants and different indications may require different
mechanisms of action to optimally cover the target.
And also they may require different drug combinations
to achieve durability.
For the majority of the history of the effort to target
RAS, it's been appreciated that the oncogenic
mutants are truly constitutively active, and this is actually not the
case. But it's only about a little over a decade ago that it was
seen that
particularly G12C and G12D, as Frank mentioned,
retain very significant intrinsic GTP hydrolysis
potential.
And this was underappreciated as a potential mechanism for addressing
these mutants with direct therapeutics.
Around the same time in Frank's lab, we worked
through the gift of the RAS-less mess from Mirana Barbasid.
We were able to put together an isogenic cell panel to look at the individual
contributions of each of these mutants, and really to look at how the signaling
output could differ pretty dramatically between different mutants.
And what we saw was actually confirming what you can see here on the
intrinsic GTP hydrolysis, that the
kinetics and the extent of the
induction of RAS GTP loading, as well as
downstream MAP kinase output, really does depend on
how much residual GTPase activity there is in each of these mutants.
With G12C clearly being the one most open to
that ability to be activated, G12D
showing a more stable activation, and G12V
showing a higher basal signal, less dependence on upstream RTK
at baseline.
So at Quana, we've taken the approach to targeting KRAS
with an understanding that you really need full coverage of the oncogenic
mutant, but you also want to block the cooperative signaling
known to occur
when you have
the wild-type form of KRAS still present.
So what we did was design, and this was led by
Quana's lead med chemist, Hong Lin, who really
drove an intense med chem and also structural biology
effort to achieve a molecule called 3034,
which is a potent KRAS inhibitor that has the ability to fully
cover G12D in the inactive state
while fully sparing wild type NRAS and HRAS.
And we hypothesized that this would best perform in the
combination with upstream inhibitor of EGFR, as
this has been demonstrated to be able to turn RAS more into that
inactive state, allow for more efficient off-state trapping, and also to
block the known feedback mechanisms where you get compensatory
upregulation of EGFR signals after you block RAS and MAP
kinase signaling. This indeed conferred
synergy across various cell lines, looking at different cancer
types, also different mutants. Although this is a G12D inhibitor, it
also can potently inhibit G12B in the context of this upstream
block, and it also can help to suppress
wild-type KRAS amplification as well.
Using a commonly used PDAC model, the HPAC model,
this is G12D,
we took what we knew to be a suboptimal dose of 3034, and what
we saw was that this could slow tumor growth, but not produce
any impact on tumor regression. Similar to
cetuximab on its own, which is known to have very limited impact in pancreatic
cancer. But when you combine the two, you're able to see...
Oops, sorry about that.
Sorry. So when you combine the two, you're able to see tumor
regressions in the majority of the mice.
And if you go up to a higher dose of 3034, that was sufficient to
produce tumor stasis or tumor regressions in a portion of the
mice. Combine that with cetuximab, all of the tumors regressed
deeply.
So this really validated that there is potential for G12D
to more efficiently trap inactive with this allosteric mechanism.
And for G12C, we know in the clinic that there is significant
validation of this combination as well.
So if you look at really all of the G12C inhibitors that have reported data so far,
CRC is by far the least sensitive tumor
type across the board. But when you combine with cetuximab, if
you look in the darker blue, it reaches the top of what's seen across
all these different direct inhibitors.
More recently, what we've seen is this carries over even into non-small
cell lung cancer in the first line, where a G12C inhibitor combined with
cetuximab has shown much higher response rates as well
as significantly deeper responses than what was seen in monotherapy.
Unfortunately, going back to colorectal cancer, what we've seen is that there is a
high propensity for resistance, and this resistance most
often occurs through the reactivation of RTK to RAS signaling.
And that often happens by amplification of RTKs, as well as
amplification of KRAS or mutations on KRAS.
So given multi-KRAS activity being potentially
important for this synergistic mechanism with EGFR,
we took forward QTX-3034, the multi-KRAS inhibitor,
with ability to fully cover G12D up to above the
EC90 trough threshold, which we projected is where we would see
clinical activity.
This data was presented by Ignacio
Garrido Laguna at the Triple Meeting last year, and what
was shown was thatAt these efficacious dose
levels, the top two doses 800 or 1200, we're able to
produce major molecular responses or reductions in KRAS
G12D ctDNA down to more than
90%
in a majority of all the patients where we have this data on the study and
across different tumor types, so looking at endometrial, colorectal, and
PDAC.
There was also a correlation observed with the
radiographic
response in all of these indications being
seen when we see these reductions in the G12D ctDNA.
Importantly, to validate the thesis that it is
essential to spare NRAS and HRAS for combination with
EGFR without exacerbation of the known cetuximab AE profile,
we did not see any rash on monotherapy with
the KRAS inhibitor alone, and when we combined with cetuximab, there was no
aggravation of that rash. There were also no DLTs or
treatment-related AEs above Grade 3 on the study.
So historically,
in PDAC in particular,
cetuximab has shown limited to no therapeutic value.
But in combination with a KRAS inhibitor, as we showed preclinically,
we expect to see significant synergy which could convert a
tumor-suppressive impact to a true tumor regression impact.
And what we saw early in our clinical study was that on monotherapy, though the
numbers are small, what we're seeing is we're able to produce tumor
shrinkage but not to the degree of regression or objective response, sorry.
And what we see is that there's significant disease control in a good portion of
the patients,
and this disease control rate is comparable to what we're seeing on the
combination.
But on the combination uniquely, what we're able to achieve is true
objective responses which appear to be largely durable.
Looking at the stable disease patients, though, across
monotherapy and combination, we see a similar rate of disease control
over six months.
And in fact, in the monotherapy, there is a patient, one out of eight
here, which is on therapy after over 15 months, and so
truly an impact in stabilization of that disease.
But in the combination,
which was really the critical thesis that we wanted to test for this molecule,
we were able to demonstrate in a patient here, we're just showing this
example where this patient has G12D and MTAP
loss at the start of the study,
came in after treatment with neoadjuvant gemcitabine, Whipple's procedure,
and adjuvant folfirinox, a very aggressive prior treatment,
then had a recurrence in the liver.
And after enrollment on the study and 15 days in,
we saw a complete clearance of their G12D ctDNA, and
by the first scan, a significant shrinkage, which
was accompanied by a reduction in the tumor marker CA19-9
over 90%.
Over the following scans, there was a
partial response that was subsequently confirmed,
and through nine months, we saw continued deepening of this
partial response.
And after
over 300 days on therapy, what was observed was
unfortunately radiographic PD with acquired KRAS
wild-type amplification. And this was interesting because we knew
that 3034 was not designed to fully cover wild-type
KRAS in the context of amplification, and so this is really an avenue where you
could further improve upon the mechanism.
So what we know now is that there are really two opportunities with
allosteric inhibition to effectively trap
KRAS away from its effectors, so you can block GTP
loading by blocking SOS-mediated exchange.
Then also, as Frank showed, there's ability to shift into a
state which is incompetent for effector interactions.
Both of these mechanisms are supported by the upstream combination with
a RTK block, so for example, EGFR
inhibition which produces synergistic activity in the combination
with allosteric KRAS inhibitor and may also help to overcome the known
supportive signaling which occurs through the wild-type KRAS alleles which are
present.
This combo has produced much higher response rates in CRC and
now lung cancer. We believe that it has strong potential in PDAC as well.
But to take the next step forward on this allosteric mechanism, as Frank
also shared,
hitting both activity states off and on with these
inhibitors has shown ability to produce
strong preclinical activity across really the large
majority of KRAS forms that we know are present in human cancers.
But the issue is that the depth of coverage is highly variable at the active
doses. And so to get to one molecule that has
one dose that's effective sufficiently for all these mutants is going to be very
challenging, but we believe that's a challenge that everyone should be taking on
right now. The first wave of these inhibitors will
definitely have a struggle with getting to a dose level
which is sufficient for this, but we think that there's an opportunity,
particularly in the combination with EGFR therapies, which are going to
produce more uniformity in how these
different alleles are performing and also
potentially deepen the responses through the blockade
of the supportive signals that we know EGFR drives,
particularly in the context of KRAS inhibition.
Our focus at Quana has
really become colorectal cancer and addressing the unique challenges that this
indication presents. It's the third most common cancer.
It is the second leading cause of cancer-related deaths with a very
low five-year survival rate with patients with advanced disease.
And this is occurring in an increasingly young population.We know that this is
largely a KRAS-driven disease with over 40% of CRC
patients presenting with a KRAS mutation.
And there are approvals now for the G12C inhibitors, so two are approved
in this setting and only in the combination with a EGFR antibody.
So we know that there is a playbook now to go after additional mutants,
and the first one being G12D, which as you see is much more
prevalent. But there's still this issue of disease heterogeneity, so there's
often multiple drivers in CRC,
and we know that the cellular plasticity is higher than in other indications as
well. So these are resistance mechanisms that we're going to have to address
through broader targeting. Either broader targeting on RAS or
KRAS, broader through cytotoxic activity, combination with
chemotherapy, or both of those. It's likely to be
required to truly have a durable impact.
We're looking at multiple potentials for further combos with this
mechanism. There are bispecifics with EGFR, so
EGFR LGAR5, which has been shown to better address the
stem-like niche within the CRC tumors.
EGFR MET, which we know that when you block EGFR potently, you get
an upregulation of MET commonly, and so this could help to delay that impact.
And also, of course, combination with immunotherapies, which has so far been off
the table but could be unlocked in MSS CRC
by the ability of a KRAS inhibitor to revert the tumor
microenvironment into a more conducive one for PDL1 and PD1
to those agents to have efficacy.
Of course, the important thing to address is going to be looking at how well
tolerated can all these combos be.
We know that so far it's been challenging to go after pan
RAS, given
the rash and mucositis, which is conferred by that mechanism being overlapping
with EGFR. But there's still a lot of
room for further investigation there, and we expect
that the learnings are going to help to inform really what is the optimal profile
when it comes to the breadth of activity of each of these agents.
Our belief at Quanta is that you're going to need thorough coverage of the
particular mutant that you want to hit, but also blocking the cooperative wild type
signaling. And you can do that effectively through the combination with these
upstream inhibitors.
But in all cases, you're going to want to move to earlier therapy, that you will
truly need for particularly indications where you have the heterogeneity that is
seen in CRC, you're going to need to hit it hard and hit it early.
You can best do that by combining with chemotherapy in the front line
or early in the course of treatment.
So we are evaluating this now with 3034, with a
study that's ongoing with 3034 cetuximab and modified
FOLFOX. In both the first and second-line population,
we believe that there could be clinical benefit in both
of these settings, but first understanding that we have the safety to pursue this
route.
So as we push forward in really trying to optimize,
we're taking forward the learnings that we're
seeing from the clinic and trying to incorporate those into
understanding what is the optimal profile, what is the optimal breadth, how do you
fully cover each of these alleles,
and how do you get to a dose which is going to enable the broadest combinations?
And we think we've landed on that with a new molecule that we're advancing,
6255, which is uniquely potent across various mutants
and able to address the
less common mutants such as G13D.
It has demonstrated really unprecedented oral bioavailability, and this has been a
challenge for the entire class due to the fact that all these molecules
are beyond rule of five and have very challenging
chemistry to really understand that you have those translational properties.
But getting to oral bioavailability at this level, we expect will reduce the
heterogeneity or the variability in patient
exposure, which has limited efficacy to date.
And we are projecting that we'd have a much lower dose, which could enable
potentially lower GIEs, which have also plagued this class.
So just wanted to share some data on what we're achieving with this molecule.
It's been able to demonstrate in a commonly used lung model, H441,
with G12V, that down to a low dose of 10 mg VID,
we're able to produce deep tumor regressions, and at 30 mg VID, we're able to
produce target coverage above the EC90 in both plasma
and tumor over the full duration.
Going back to G13D, it's highly prevalent
in colorectal cancer. It's the third most common mutant seen in
colorectal cancer
among the KRAS alleles.
And what was demonstrated also in this work by the Westover
group out of UT Southwestern was that it has unique
GTP exchange kinetics, really different from what we're seeing from the other
alleles.
And that this really gives it a distinct activity, which
may be producing a different challenge for allosteric inhibition.
But what we've seen is that we're able to cover G13D at
single-digit nanomolar levels consistent with what we're seeing across the other
mutants. And so this is something that really encourages us to look
deeper, particularly in light of the fact that the first wave of
inhibitors in the clinic are leaving this one on the table, and
that with
the initial pan KRAS inhibitors, we know that their preference for
G12D, and it's challenging to fully cover G13D.
It's interesting that with the pan RAS molecules, and I think there's a lot more
to learn here, but we know that they have ability to
produce GTPase activity on the protein.
So part of the mechanism is after it binds, it has GTPase or
encourages the GTPase function of KRAS.
And so when it is turning offIf you have G13D
and these rapid GTP exchange kinetics, you're able to rapidly turn back on, and
that could be reactivating the RAS signal.
But what we're seeing is that with 6255, we're getting one to two log
improvement in efficacy and
the ability to cover the downstream output of also ERK
across different G13D models.
But there's room for further improvement here, and we expect that's going to come
through combinations as well. So we've shown here EGFR combination, either
small molecule or antibody, and also SHP2, which
produces a broader impact in blocking RTKs,
which synergizes quite well across the different models.
And interestingly also TEAD inhibition, which is a kind of
parallel pathway, but one that produces an impact where we could have a much lower
dose of the K-RAS inhibitor that could be sufficient for full coverage
of the mutant.
We also want to be able to go to where things are headed, and we expect
that there will be near-term approval for pan-RAS inhibitors
such as draxlarasib, and so we want to look at the resistance in that setting.
Several in the field have now shown that there
is potential for the loss of cyclophilin, which should not impact direct
inhibitors. And what we saw in our own labs was
that this does not happen overnight, but after prolonged treatment
with RMC-6236, you see a loss of cyclophilin
due to a point mutation which produces a complete loss of the protein.
The cancer cells do not require this protein to continue to
grow, and our mechanism of action and binding does not
require cyclophilin A, and so what we see is that
both looking at the output on MAP kinase signaling as well as
antiproliferative impact, we're able to retain very potent activity in this
setting.
Still, we believe that across the board with various K-RAS mutants,
the ones that are on, the ones that can shift off, it really doesn't
matter. All of them are going to benefit
to a large degree from upstream blockade and starting with EGFR.
And we're showing here that with our potent on and off state
inhibitor of K-RAS covering M full G12V down to low
doses of 10 mg or 30 mg, we're able to produce an impact
in
really blocking the tumor growth and producing some shrinkage, but
there is outgrowth over time. If you combine with cetuximab, you're able to
suppress that, and we think that this is going to be valuable in the combination.
But ultimately, to get to the most robust outcomes, we think
that you really do need to engage
immunity against the tumor. That for the potential for
actual eradication of tumor, you certainly will need to
have an impact on the immune system,
and K-RAS inhibitors can contribute to that.
So we know that direct inhibition of K-RAS produces a
shift in what the cancer cells can do to create this immunosuppressive tumor
microenvironment. You increase immune activation signals, and you decrease
immune suppressive signals, and that this could allow for
effective combination with IO agents in settings that have been
intractable to date.
So with all this, we believe that we have a molecule that's going to
allow us to look very broadly at the various settings where
K-RAS inhibitors will be important, to look across various mutants, to look
at all the combinations that could be attractive.
And because we have really unprecedented oral bioavailability here,
could go after a full breadth of mutants and
potentially
also have a lower drug load, which could produce a
reduction of GIAs, which have been a true challenge for this field.
And we've so far seen in dogs that there is
certainly a more attractive profile with a lower dose.
So this is ongoing, and we expect to be able to file an IND based on the studies
which are underway later this year.
So with that, I'd like to thank all of the patients and investigators that
participated in the clinical evaluation of 3034.
This has been incredibly informative as we look to further optimize on
these therapies. And also thank the Quanta drug discovery
and developing colleagues that put together this work, and thank you for
listening.
Happy to take any questions.
If anybody has a question, we have to go to the microphone, please.
Carla.
I have a question while Noel's getting to the microphone.
Okay.
I was actually really intrigued by the responses in the
endometrial patients. I know it was a small group, and I was wondering if
you know anything about the genotypes because those tend to be pretty
complex in terms of their mutational landscape.
Yeah, that's true. So
just to kind of back up. What we saw in our dose escalation was that
endometrial cancer was particularly responsive to this mechanism, multi
K-RAS G12D, but really only the endometrioid
population. So there's various forms of endometrial cancer, but all the
endometrioid were clearly responsive
despite having a lot of genetic complexity.
PI3-kinase mutations, other things that you don't think that could
be truly fully impacted by this mechanism.
Still, we saw really robust responses and durable responses over time.
So this is definitely an indication that has a lot of scientific
rationale to go after, but it's a small population, and it is tough to
enroll. So as we
accumulate more data, we'll be able to generate more hypotheses around where to go
next.
Now I have more than one thing to say.
Number one, I have to think we
owe to Frank McCormick,
who's well known as an endometrial
researcher. He was the one who reported the fact that approximately
50% of endometrials
havePTEN loss and PI3K alpha
mutation, and of those, about
15% have RAS mutation. The question I have
is, and you didn't say anything about this, is as
opposed to pancreas and the lung, which had
minuscule frequency
of PI3K mutation, colorectal cancer has 25%
to 30%. Do you have any idea of what it's doing there?
And secondly, in what you showed on colorectal
patients of models, were they selected
for no PI3K? A lot of them have wild-type
PI3K.
Right.
Did you select
for PI3K wild type or...
Yeah, we didn't select for PI3K wild type, but the models that we're
showing, I believe, are PI3K wild type. We don't know.
We have a lot of patient data emerging in colorectal cancer now, and so that's
another level that we're going to have to look.
But so far what we've seen is no real impact,
at least at a high level of having these additional
PI3-kinase mutations.
But that's really just looking at the upfront response ability to
suppress ctDNA to see early responses.
Durability could potentially be impacted by those additional mutants.
We actually have a manuscript that has not yet been
rejected
with Malka,
showing that the PI3Ks are less sensitive,
and they're probably... We haven't done this exhaustively.
One part of this is the decreased ability of the RAS
inhibitor to
suppress cyclin D expression.
Mm-hmm.
Which makes sense-
Makes sense. Yeah
... by raw.
Thanks, Neil.
Another question over there.
Hi. That's very nice presentation, but I'm
having one, not question, query.
You send samples for sequencing in the resistance cells as well
as parental cells, and you mentioned the drug concentration as well
as vehicle cell percentage, but I'm
curious how you selected that time point of sending
the samples for sequencing, and which time point you have
used in this particular experiment to find out the mechanism of
resistance. Thank you.
Yeah. It was really based on when we saw a complete loss of
sensitivity to the pan-RAS inhibitor.
That's when we decided that it would make sense to look for
what is that mechanism of action. We saw that there was a restoration of
MAP kinase signaling, so we wanted to see
how is that occurring. Of course, one rational
reason would be because you can no longer bind to the target, but
that hadn't been reported at the time that we generated that data.
So,
yeah, the time point, it was months into treatment.
So it wasn't like this was a rapid effect.
But we saw it in multiple clonal
studies.
Oh, okay. Thank you.
Hi. I would like to know what is, from your perspective and the research
that you have done,
what is the best partner in term of combination and
to achieve the best efficacy but with lower toxicity and
why?
Yeah.
All of these agents that target full nodes
have significant tox. And so really if we want
durability, it's always going to come with, you're going to have to weigh these
things against each other.
What
we believe is that hitting upstream hard does truly matter.
If you could dose a SHP2 inhibitor in
combination with a K-RAS inhibitor, you would have the broadest
impact on those upstream signals, but we know that that is largely toxic.
So yeah, you're really going to have to figure out where is it tolerated.
So far, we've seen with the EGFR combo is very
encouraging. There's
more emerging data on EGFR MET now, and that could be better
in preventing this. We know that MET is a true issue in resistance to
EGFRs.
But yeah, I think it's really going to come down to the setting and
really weighing the tolerability and
looking at the long-term impact.
Okay. Thank you.
Anybody else out there? I can't see. There's one.
You have a question? Oh.
Can I ask a question?
The compound covered most of the mutant.
Is it work for G12R? G12R has a
substance of percentage in pancreatic cancer.
Yes.
So is this some compound selectively targeting G12R?
Thank you.
Yes. No, it significantly loses activity against V12R because of the
allosteric mechanism. So the allosteric mechanism really does depend on both the
inactive state and the active state activity.
G12R is fully in the active state,
but we do see
sub-micromolar activity across the board in the G12R setting.
We just don't believe that that's going to be sufficient to focus on that
population,
at least in the early stages in the clinic, until we understand the
windows that we have.
But yeah, it is a very important mutation.
It's the fourth most common in PDAC, but it isn't really seen outside of PDAC.
And our
focus right now, at least at Quanta, is on colorectal cancer, where G12R
is very rarely seen.
Yeah. Right.
Based on your knowledge, do you know some G12R selective compound
except the revolusimab one?
I don't think there is a G12R selective
compoundAvailable. I think the Revolution Medicines approach
is great for G12R because it's always on, and
Revolution Medicines always hits the on state.
But for direct allosteric inhibition, there really
isn't the avenue to
fully cover G12R at a dose that we think is going to be attractive as of
yet. But we'll see when we end up in the clinic and look at the exposure, there may
be a chance.
Okay. Thank you.
Hey.
Thanks again, Cameron. That was great.
Thank you. Our next speaker is Mallika Singh, who's senior vice president
at Revolution Medicine.
So she's still on a high from last week's news releases.
I promised you I wouldn't tear up.
Yeah, she said she wouldn't cry, but if you do, feel free.
No.
Done a lot of that in the last week.
So, thank you the organizing committee, and thank you, Frank, for the opportunity
to present some of our work today. And I love
that a lot of my introductory slides have been taken care of. All right.
So let's see how this works.
These are my disclosures.
And again, as you just heard, very elegantly,
that there are normal cellular mechanisms that
really keep the canonical RAS proteins, particularly
KRAS, NRAS, or HRAS in a very tightly regulated state.
Frank really outlined that very beautifully.
This is just a cartoon to just remind you that that tight
regulation is altered, again, as Frank showed you in great detail,
by these hotspot mutations, primarily at codons 12, 13, and 61
in the canonical RAS proteins. And you've heard a lot about some of the diseases
that are really impacted by these canonical RAS proteins as drivers
and remain a huge unmet medical need.
I'm going to zoom in to a little bit of history, that
really zooms in on the last decade or so.
And again, the work of so many people here in this
room, as well as particularly including Frank,
starting with the discovery of the human RAS oncogenes in the 1980s, preceded,
of course, in the '60s by the discovery of the viral oncogenes.
And then I'm going to come back to this point that in the late
'90s,
this idea that was really based in the work of both
Tyler Jacks as well as Mariano Barbacid, looking at knockouts of these
canonical RAS oncogenes and showing that certain sets of these,
particularly KRAS, are lethal in the embryonic state.
And thus the dogma that has really prevailed in the field
that inhibiting these canonical oncogenes altogether would not be
possible or be tolerated in adult mammals.
Then, of course, the seminal work of starting with work from Kevan Shokat, John
Ostrem, and Ulf Peters and colleagues,
leading to the discovery of the first orally bioavailable RAS off inhibitors, two
of which are approved, as you heard.
And then in 2020, we actually
disclosed the first orally bioavailable RAS on inhibitors that I'll
spend the rest of the talk about.
In 2022, actually at AACR in New Orleans,
so obviously we love this meeting, we disclosed the existence of, at the time,
four orally bioavailable RAS on inhibitors, and that
was the first being RMC-6236, now known as Deruxon-Rasib.
And later that year, we dosed our first patient with
RMC-6236, now Deruxon-Rasib. In
2023,
at ESMO, Casey Arbor gave a plenary at which
we disclosed the initial activity of Deruxon-Rasib in patients
with RAS mutant non-small cell lung cancer and pancreatic cancer
at doses where we had first predicted we would first see tumor shrinkage.
We continued dose escalating. We also disclosed, again at
AACR in 2024, a couple of years ago now,
the concepts behind what is called now pan-RAS
inhibition or RAS multi-inhibition by using RMC-7977, a
tool compound, as well as the structure of RMC-6236.
Fast forward to today, we have four pivotal studies, one
of which, as most of you know, read out in the last week, Resolute
302,
treating patients with pancreatic cancer in the second line following a relapse
on first-line chemotherapy, and Resolute
302, 303 is still ongoing,
met all primary and secondary endpoints, including PFS and
OS in the intent to treat population, and we did not see any new
safety signals in this particular study.
We still have three ongoing pivotal studies, as I just mentioned,
particularly Resolve 301, that continues to enroll in the second-line
non-small cell lung cancer setting with
Deruxon-Rasib as a monotherapy, as well as now looking at
early-stage pancreatic cancer or resectable disease, as
well as frontline, both as a monotherapy and in combination with
gem/nab paclitaxel in this case.
All right. Frank has already really walked through this very nicely, as did
Cameron. But just a reminder, again, in looking at the
GTPase cycle here, simplified without the gaps and the gefs, to
show you again the history of these targeting RAS strategies that you really
heard throughout this session, and that is primarily focused on what
you heard was some really elegant chemistry, and then follow on with
different types of switch II pocket binders that either bind to the off state and
now to the off and the on state. Particularly elegant in
terms of what's been done by locking it, as Frank showed you, in a particular
state and really starting to access the GTP-bound state.
What I'm going to focus on for the rest of the talk is our approach at Revolution
Medicines, which is what we call the tricomplex approach that
uses large small molecules to essentially bring a
chaperone protein, cyclophilin A, that I'll show you in great detail
over the next few slides,
in forming this tricomplex that then occludes
sterically the binding and hence shuts down downstream
signaling via all of the effectors that Frank showed you, the RAF
proteins, the PI3 kinase proteins, as well as
RalGDS.What was really interesting and is a
discovery that Frank also alluded to is that in the
non-covalent versions of this tricomplex, the tricomplex formed by Deraxone rasib,
work published by Piroletto in the last year, as well as
work that we've shown, is it also stimulates some
GTPase activity. So there is some hydrolysis of the terminal
phosphate in the formation of the tricomplex that results
in forming a fraction of this or shutting this down by turning it
into the GDP state. So it's a dual mode of action.
You'll hear a lot more, obviously, in how we've continued to innovate
and build upon this knowledge from Jan Smith on
Tuesday. I have a list of some of our presentations coming up at
this conference later on in this talk.
So all of our RASON inhibitors act in the same way in this mechanism of action
outlined here. The RASON inhibitors are shown in gold.
All of these enter the cell and bind to, again, a very abundant chaperone
protein, cyclophilin A, shown here in beige, forming this binary complex.
It's the binary complex and only the binary complex that undergoes a series of
conformational changes that enable it to bind to Ras
GDP, shown here in green, forming the tricomplex, shown here
in the middle. Optimization of all of the interactions at the
tricomplex interface, and I'll show you a zoom-in in the next few slides,
really led to first the discovery of Deraxone rasib, the multi-selective inhibitor,
and then continuing to build on those SARs, and I'll show you how
we've changed some of those interactions to build on mutant
selectivity,
starting with RMC-5127, our G12V selective inhibitor, which is now
currently in the clinic, as well as a Q61H selective.
And then really some amazing chemistry to build on this
to find covalent warheads led to the discovery of Eleron
rasib, our G12C selective inhibitor, as well as Zoldon rasib, our G12D
selective inhibitor, as well as the G13C selective inhibitor.
And again, all of these form the tricomplex.
And here you can really start to see how the steric clash occurs with
cyclophilin A, and I'll show you that in a video in a
few slides from now.
Oh, that's now. Okay.
Here's the pineapple, as we affectionately call it,
flipped over.
And so what you're now looking at is zooming in on that
tricomplex interface, now focusing on Deraxone rasib.
You can see the structural basis for the mechanism of action or
multi-selective nature of Deraxone in that you can see now zooming in
the back of Deraxone here and in this tricomplex interface, leaving
this beautiful groove or this tunnel, which contains
all of those hotspot residues that we all focus on, G12, G13, and
Q61. And so that really drove the
ability and the discovery of the fact that Deraxone disrupts
RAS-RAF interactions in this particular case in a biochemical assay,
both with the wild-type canonical RAS proteins, as well as within very narrow
potency ranges, all of the mutants that we had looked at the time, hence the
name multi-selective. Here's the structure that we disclosed over on the bottom
right. And I think the amazing chemist whose group
built this, Elena Colton, is somewhere here in the audience.
The light's in my face. Oh, there she is.
And,
again, now looking at turning this,
what you can see is, first of all, how the tricomplex
interface forms at a very conserved part of the molecule because the
non-conserved residues are all here in blue out here in the bottom.
And then when you turn it over, here you can see that steric clash that I was
talking about very clearly, where cyclophilin essentially reaches over and
glomming onto RAS and really creates an inability of, in this
case, the RAS binding domain of CRAF to bind.
Leveraging on many, many SAR handles, I won't read all of the
black arrows here, but this is all what an amazingly talented
chemistry team has used to build now
a diverse library of RAS on tricomplex inhibitors that we're starting
to leverage in combinations, as I'll show you later on in the talk.
And that's really led, again, like I said, on one hand, to these very, very
selective covalent inhibitors, and then on the other hand, now
multi-selective or mutant-selective non-covalent inhibitors.
Little bit more along those lines here, just to
show you how we're playing with those SAR handles and that
selectivity. On this slide, bear with me, it's a little bit complicated.
On the top row, you have either electron density maps or, in the case of
Deraxone, the space filling in the boxes here to remind me that I'll focus on
Deraxone for the rest of the talk. But here, what I'm showing you is, again,
the addition of a covalent warhead here in the case of G12C, one of the
first covalent inhibitors we made.
And then looking at the bottom, what you're seeing is either RAS mutant lines in
green, so these are cell lines looking at proliferation, or wild type
lines in blue. And you see this exquisite selectivity for
Eleron by the space between the green and the blue.
Zoldon, very interestingly, because of the nature of D, where we
put in a very slow covalent warhead, you see a little bit of the mixing of the
green and the blue. So this starts giving you an idea of how much you can
play with the selectivity with these inhibitors, because we also know,
based on the safety profile of Zoldon, that this is extremely
well-tolerated. And so this amount of noise does not seem to be
playing out or can be tolerated in the clinical setting.
And then again, of course, with Deraxone, you see lots of mixing.
And now what you can see here is building into the tunnel in
such a way that you're bulking out what was starting as a Deraxone rasib
scaffold into the pocket, and such that you only
exclude the
binding of other mutants except V.
And so now you start to see the green and the blue separate again in the genesis of
RMC-5127, with whom we dosed our first patient now
a couple of months ago.All right. Focusing on duraxon rasib for
the rest of the talk. What you can see here is when we found we
had duraxon rasib, we had two challenges or two dogmas that we needed to
challenge on our hands. One was we really wanted to go into the
clinic very quickly into an exquisitely selected patient
population, such that we really wanted a precision medicine strategy to
understand if duraxon would be safe and would be effective.
To do that, we did a series of in vitro and in vivo screens.
What you can see on this are our three figures that describe that work
done in collaboration with the Prism group and Andy Aguirre.
And on the left, what you're looking at is a volcano plot showing the genetic
determinants of sensitivity on the left and lack of sensitivity on the
right. So again, KRAS by far is the highest
determinant of sensitivity to duraxon rasib and whereas
BRAF, which in this collection of cells is primarily V600
mutants, is insensitive as you would expect.
So this was our first clue that we had a RAS selective inhibitor on our hands.
And then binning all of these Prism 800 or so cell lines by
codon, what you also see is, again, 12 is exquisitely
sensitive and of course, is the most abundant mutation in KRAS.
And so, the other experiment that we did, the thought experiment over on the right
is look at DepMap and look at the effect of KRAS knockout and
look at it binned by the same codons that we had looked at in
duraxon over here on the left. And again, interestingly, you see the same
exact pattern that we did in terms of the binning of the mutations and the
sensitivities saying, again, really confirming that we had a RAS selective
inhibitor on our hands. We did a series of in vivo experiments.
All of this work is published, so I'm going through it really quickly.
And showed again that in non-small cell lung cancer and
in pancreatic cancer, consistent with the incredible
dependence of these diseases on KRAS G12,
you see really nice tumor shrinkage, which is extremely durable, as shown by
these Kaplan-Meier analyses in three-month long experiments.
Colorectal as Cameron really nicely outlined, different beast, and you
definitely see heterogeneous responses to monotherapy, in this case, both in
the preclinical and as predicted in the clinical setting with all
RAS inhibitors. We, of course, went into more high-bar
models that we believe in, and I actually went and looked at this when
we got the duraxon rasib data last week.
And somebody asked me, "What did you think or what did you predict?" And
I think the survival curve tells you
the story that needs to be heard. And also the other right side, this is work we
did with Ken Olive, published now about a couple of years ago.
What you also see is what we're all seeing with the RAS inhibitors in
the clinic. After long-term treatment with a monotherapy, you get relapse.
And we went on to characterize the nature of the resistance in these,
and then recently also disclosed data in a small cohort of patients with
pancreatic cancer, again, looking at mechanisms driving resistance.
And one of the themes we're really starting to emerge from this is that resistance
goes back to the pathway. It goes back to the pathway as it does for the mutant
selective inhibitors as monotherapies, but it goes back in a different
way. In this particular case, we often see amplification of the
mutant KRAS allele in patients on duraxon rasib.
I won't have time to go into those data, so I wanted to allude to that here, but I
wanted to get to the other side of the dogma that we were facing, which
was we didn't know, again, what the tolerability would be in the clinic.
So again, in the work that we did with Ken, we really did a series of
experiments to try and understand what was happening in normal tissues.
Before we did that, I did borrow this slide from Channing Der, which
also showed, again, we showed in those beautiful RASless maps that,
again, RMC-7977 in this case was a tool compound, did
actually inhibit all the different forms of RAS that we could look
at.
So in the work that we did with Ken, you can see the histological
representation here. We went in with a
hypothesis that normal tissues would behave
differently when you put therapeutic pressure on RAS because they're wired
differently, as Frank showed you really nicely. The pathways are wired differently.
And so what you can see here on the top left is
tumors. Now what you're looking at is a measure of proliferation cyclin
A2 that have been treated with RMC-7977, and you see really
nice downregulation of proliferation
quantitated over here on the right, and it's also reasonably durable, very
consistent with the pharmacokinetics of RMC-7977 in the
animal.
Now, when you look at proliferation over on the right, if
cells are wired or normal tissues are wired differently to compensate for
therapeutic pressure on RAS, what we predicted based on some
historical work, really nice work from Renee Bernards, is that we should see a very
different pattern of proliferation inhibition or apoptosis
induction. And what we indeed saw, looking at the colon, we also looked at
the skin, a very transient reduction in proliferation and very
rapid restoration of the pathway.
Here, looking at cyclin A2, and again, in tumors, we saw
florid induction of apoptosis. This was after a single dose.
We saw it again and again after repeat dosing.
And now when you look at the colon, you don't see that marked induction of
apoptosis, which is shown here in the tumors.
In fact, you rarely see any apoptotic cells looking at the colon after
multiple doses.
So putting all of those data together, we conducted
your typical IND-enabling tox experiments and then went into the clinic,
with permission from the FDA. We did a really
thoughtful dose escalation. This 80 to 120 dose is what
we first saw activity at, which we had predicted we would see it around 100
milligrams and then continued to dose escalate to 300 milligrams, which was the
dose selected for RASOLU302.These are the initial
data from that Phase I/II study, again, where we saw
importantly good tumor shrinkage both in the RAS
population, and then we also actually went on to go on to expand beyond
G12 once we saw the signals. And the teal bars here are the non
G12
mutant. And again, you can see very nice activity now beyond G12, as
again predicted by the preclinical data, with a disease control rate of
95%.
Of course, looking at durability, this is again looking at both the RAS G12
mutant population as well as the overall RAS mutant population.
And the most important thing to look here at both the PFS curve
as well as the OS curve, these are the data that really gave us
confidence to go to the agency and lobby for
RASalut302, is when you look at the lower limit of the confidence
interval, both for the PFS as well as for the overall survival,
this is greater than the median
PFS in the overall survival on standard of care for patients who go on
second-line chemotherapy. And these numbers when they were
stable really gave us confidence to drive the result
that we have recently disclosed. Of course, as has been
alluded to many times over, of course, targeting all RAS has tolerability
limits. And we do see a safety profile, again, very consistent with a
RAS selective inhibitor. We do see on-pathway effects
at higher doses, albeit they are very manageable when you look at the
Grade 3 profiles. And again, we have adopted a very
aggressive prophylaxis strategy as part of RASalut302 as well,
with the help of many investigators, some of whom are in this audience.
The most interesting thing, though, here is, and a couple important things, is no
liver signals, as has been observed for some of the switch two pocket
binders, as well as no signs of immunosuppression
because we predicted that we don't occupy most
of the cyclophilin in the cell. In fact, we occupy probably
about 10% of cyclophilin that's present in a cell at Cmax.
And so, again, much more to come, of course.
And as I said, we've now disclosed some resistance data
from this cohort of patients as well, starting to really understand the
limits of the monotherapy and what are the clues from those
resistance data, both from us as well as from Puralido from this Phase
I/II trial that really help us think about combinations.
This is a framework and I'll just spend the rest of my time talking about some
interesting combination data. And where we're headed is to how we're
thinking about some of those combination paradigms and our
learnings. And this is, again, looking into the future.
If RAS inhibition becomes a backbone, particularly for patients with
pancreatic cancer, then, as Cameron also illustrated, what we need to
start thinking about is how we're going to tackle the resistance that comes with
monotherapy. And we can get clues from baseline features of
tumors, particularly the malignant cells, as well as various
features of the tumor microenvironment from the tumors
themselves. We can learn a lot from rapid adaptation
and early signals, which we're doing in a
biopsy study that you'll hear about from Andy Aguirre in his talk,
and how we're learning very early signals that come from deruxan
rasib treatment. And you can look at post-treatment or
after relapse, what occurs in
tumors and what we can learn from these about resistance mechanisms.
And then the other paradigm that's illustrated here is what you can learn from
one setting can potentially then be translated or moved into another setting.
So maybe we are seeing learnings that were coming from the resistant
patients that we can then use into upfront combinations.
And so that's another one of the sets of experiments or types of thinking that
we're trying to apply. So I'm going to give you examples of a couple of
combination approaches that we're thinking about.
So one is, of course, with the luxury of this
amazing pipeline, we have the opportunity to actually
now think of what we think about as doubling down on RAS.
I do think Cameron raised a really interesting point, which is should you be
hitting the driver and upstream or should you be hitting the driver and hitting the
driver harder?
And I think the experiment that we are able to do currently is to hit the
driver harder so we can take advantage of the multi-selective nature
of agents like deruxan rasib, where you can inhibit both
the mutant as well as the wild type mechanisms that often arise
as drivers of resistance or drivers of increased oncogenic flux at
baseline, like they do in colorectal cancer.
And we can take advantage of the fact that the mutant selective inhibitors are
really safe, so we can use those to hit the driver harder.
We've illustrated this now pre-clinically a couple of different ways.
So on the left are data that we published last month.
Thank you again, ACR Journals.
And you can see here this is a combination of aleron rasib
and deruxan rasib in green, aleron in blue.
And now for all of these combination experiments, we go to models that are
more challenging. So models that were on the left side of the waterfall plots that
I showed you that are essentially harder to treat.
And so you can see these models initially respond but then relapse on
deruxan over a 90-day experiment.
But you see a very nice combination effect of the G12C inhibitor plus deruxan
in this case. And then over on the right, you're looking at a series of
KRAS G12D allograft models. This is the KPCY
series discovered originally in the lab of Ben Stanger that he very
kindly gives out to the community.
And again, these are relatively high bar immune competent models
that ultimately relapse both on deruxan rasib and now in this case
zoldan rasib, the G12D inhibitor, as
monotherapies. But then you also see, again, a very nice durable combination
effect when you put these two together, and you can see clear forestalling of
resistance in all of these
models.Another really interesting
approach that we've done in collaboration with Ryan Corcoran, this is
work that we presented at the AACR RAS conference last month,
and I think is also a really nice poster coming
up.
And that is this idea that, again, we can take
advantage of that hydrolysis activity of deruxon rasib and
actually think about the conformational trappers, so the switch
II pocket binders in combination with deruxon rasib to
basically target both the on forms as well as the off forms,
and some of the off form being generated by the binding of deruxon
rasib. And so now what we've done is looked in a series of
models here
with a pan-KRAS inhibitor. So again, these are really, really
resistant models. Some of these are mutant KRAS-amplified models,
so they don't respond very well to deruxon rasib at all.
So looking at this panel of models where we're pretty sure, while the
pan-KRAS doesn't do much at all as a monotherapy, deruxon
does initially show some response, but you see a
relapse on treatment very, very quickly.
You just see a really beautiful synergistic combination effect with this type of
combination, again, illustrating another way of doubling down on RAS.
Finally, of course, taking advantage, particularly in pancreatic cancer of the work
published by Andy Aguirre as well as Tuomas Tammela.
Again, really thinking about moving to the frontline, and
building on those concepts that Andy and Tuomas
published showing that in pancreatic cancer, you have cell states that are
very susceptible to RAS inhibition, but there are also cell states that
are very susceptible to chemotherapy, and these might be complementary.
So looking at the combination of deruxon rasib with chemotherapy as a
foundation for our frontline trial, RESOLUTE-303, to try and understand the
mechanisms behind this. You're looking at one model that's an example looking at
gem/nab paclitaxel responds okay, but grows out on
treatment. Responds pretty well to deruxon as a monotherapy, and then you
also see a pretty nice combination benefit.
And then looking at, again, a panel of these types of models, including some
wild-type models. Again, you
see not particularly great durability on the chemotherapy regimen, but
you see pretty nice durability for deruxon as a monotherapy, as well as a
really nice combination effect. Putting all of these data together
is really part of what drove the decision that RESOLUTE-303
will now test both deruxon as a monotherapy in the frontline,
but also looking at the combination with gem/nab paclitaxel, both being compared
to gem/nab paclitaxel as a control arm.
So I don't have time to go over a lot, lot more in the fun
resistance and combination space that we're doing.
I'll leave you with sort of a few key themes.
We, and I think many in this audience, believe that direct RAS
inhibitors are, many of whom are in development, ultimately will
be the backbone of therapy in RAS-addicted diseases like pancreatic
cancer. And we need to very rapidly understand tumor
adaptation and acquired monotherapy resistance to
leverage in the form, first of combinations, but also to inform the next
generation of RAS inhibitors that are coming along.
The preclinical data, I think has been proving very, very
informative in terms of our understandings and our predictions.
I think it is really important, as you heard from both speakers, to both hit
the driver harder, in some way hit this essential pathway, maximize
cytotoxicity, and engage the immune system.
I didn't have time to really talk about that, but again, we've published very
similar data to what Cameron showed.
We definitely see induction of tumor immunity after RAS inhibition.
And of course, there's a lot, lot more fun to be had in the drug development
space.
Many acknowledgments, beginning with the patients, their families, and all
of the investigators who are making clinical evaluation possible,
who drove everything that has happened in the last week.
Key research collaborators that I named along the way, and of course, a fantastic
group of research and development colleagues that I work with.
I'll leave you with just some advertisements for a few more interesting
presentations to come at this AACR, and I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you. That was a wonderful talk.
And congratulations to you and the company for your brilliant outcomes.
A huge game changer. We all appreciate it.
Thank you on behalf of Ravmed.
We've got time for a few questions. Hi.
Hello.
Maybe we could turn the lights down a little bit.
Very nice talk. I have a quick question.
Yeah.
How did you choose cyclophilin? How did you identify cyclophilin as a good
partner for KRAS?
That's a great question. It was actually work done at Warp Drive Bio, which we
acquired, that initially really nice work from Greg Verdine and
colleagues that
initially did this concept of the glues and leveraging
FKBP12 and cyclophilin. And what they showed is that it's the ratio of
the chaperone to the target that's really important, and so there is a
clear difference in the concentrations of RAS proteins and
cyclophilins in the cell that enable cyclophilin to be a
good chaperone in this particular case.
Okay, thanks.
Mm-hmm.
Hello. Great talk.
I do have a question on your data for both clinical or
preclinical.
Did you guys look at any responses of different pancreatic subtypes,
like basal or classical?
We are currently doing that work now at this
point, and I think a lot of that is going to come from the biopsy study that I
alluded to where we're just starting to investigate that.
Hi.
Thank you very much.
A beautiful presentation. Just one quick question
regarding your increased GTP hydrolysis
induced by deruxon. Do you guys see this
in your other compounds?
So the covalent inhibitors-
You just, yeah
... do not, you wouldn't see hydrolysis in the case of the covalent bond
formation.
But what about your mutant selective compounds?
We have not disclosed that information.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi.
Carlos.
Great work.
A quick question that I have is what do you think will be the main
driver of resistant to Deruxon as you
move into broader clinical trials?
So thus far, what we've seen is altogether, if you
put the data that Piero has out on BioRxiv as well as the data that
we disclosed at ENA,
it looks like about at least half of the resistance mechanisms, the
genomic resistance mechanisms that we can see, somewhere between 50% and
60%,
go back to the pathway based on ctDNA data.
About
half of that, so 60% of that in the case of patients with pancreatic
cancer is amplification of the mutant allele.
So clearly the tumors evolve to reactivate the pathway.
The other, depending on what numbers you look at, 40% to
50% clearly are driven by non-genomic mechanisms where I think there's
a lot more work to be done.
I see. Okay. Thanks.
Great presentation. Congrats on the Deruxon rasov phase three
success. So I have a question. I have been reading a
bit about KRAS inhibition, and I came
across a new agent that your company is testing,
RM-055,
and it has some pretty good preclinical results from what
I've seen.
How did your
scientists address the resistance that you've been seeing with Deruxte rejuseb?
Yeah, that's pretty much my question.
I suggest you go to the presentation on Tuesday.
All right. Thank you.
Good answer.
You might have the same answer to my question.
We heard from
the second talk today that there is supposedly anything
happening with cyclophilin A in terms of resistance.
I hadn't seen anything before this, but maybe you can give a
statement on this. Do you see anything that happens to cyclophilin A in
terms of resistance?
Very early data from patients. So of course there have been reports, as
Cameron pointed out, of cyclophilin loss in cell culture.
Very early data from patients between our work
that'll be presented by Andy Aguirre, looking at cyclophilin levels
in the biopsy study that I alluded to.
Very early on, we do not see any significant changes in cyclophilin
levels in tumor cells.
And Piero was able to sequence cyclophilin in, I believe,
six patients of a cohort of about 40
and did not see any changes.
Thanks a lot. And again, we should all
really congratulate you to what you have achieved for the patients.
I think it's really great.
Thank you.
I was just curious about the 10% of PDAC patients that
are KRAS wild type. Is there any preclinical or clinical data
supporting Deruxon rasib in that population?
There is. In that chemo set, there's definitely some wild
type models as well. So we definitely see activity.
And that's not surprising because there's really nice data showing that
a lot of that subset is dependent on the pathway, even
if Ras is wild type. So you often will see RTK fusions
or BRF class three mutations. So we would predict
that some of those would be sensitive to Deruxon.
And patients who are KRAS wild type were
enrolled in Resolute302.
Thank you.
Cameron has a question.
Great talk. So I was just wondering how much of the safety of the pan-RAS mechanism
do you attribute to the GTPase activity that's stimulated with
these non-covalent molecules?
Oh, that's a good question. I don't know if we've
modeled that in normal tissues.
I was just wondering because you show the normal tissues, you do see some transient
apoptosis signals and-
Yep
... if that restoration could be due to that GTPase function.
That's a really good point. Jen, have we modeled that in normal tissue at all?
I don't think so. Yeah. Really good question.
Zhibo.
Hi, I have a question. Based on the waterfall
plot you just saw, in preclinical study,
the 6236 doesn't work well for some
models, particularly colorectal cancer
xenograft-
Mm-hmm
... that are harboring G12D mutation and
also for G12A mutation. Out of the
G12A mutation, for G12A mutation, only one
achieved the regression. All of the rest are some inhibition.
So I'm wondering, is this kind of efficacy will be
translated to patient? Is the
clinical data in patient is consistent with the preclinical
data?
We disclosed some very early data for Deruxon in
colorectal, and the data are consistent with our preclinical predictions.
So that means 6236 doesn't work
well for certain kind of
patient that have, particularly for colorectal cancer
patients, that are harboring G12A and
G12D mutations?
I don't think we have the amount of data to actually look at the
allele level. The overall data that we've disclosed is consistent
with our predictions of lower activity in patients with colon cancer.
I don't think we have dug into the specific allele questions that you're
asking, but happy to discuss that further.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
With that, I'll thank Malika and Cameron and all of you for your attention, and
have a great rest of the meeting. Thank you.
Hooray